Dear fellow scholars.
This is two minute papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér. In early 2019,
a learning based technique appeared that could perform common,
natural language processing operations. For instance, answering questions,
completing text, reading, comprehension, summarization, and more.
This method was developed by scientists at open AI and they called it
GPT two.
The goal was to be able to perform this task with as little supervision as
possible.
This means that they unleashed disagree with them to read the internet.
And the question was what would the AI learn during this process?
That is a tricky question. And to be able to answer it,
have a look at this paper from 2017,
where an AI was given a bunch of Amazon product reviews,
and the goal was to teach it to be able to generate new ones or continue a
review. When given one, then something unexpected happened.
The finished neural network used surprisingly few neurons to be able to continue
these reviews.
They noticed that the neural network has built up a knowledge of not only
language, but also build a sentiment detector as well.
This means that the AI recognized that in order to be able to continue a review,
it not only needs to learn English,
but also needs to be able to detect whether the review seems positive or
not. If we know that we have to complete a review,
that seems positive from a small snippet,
we have a much easier time doing it well.
And now back to GPT two,
as it was asked to predict the next character in sentences of not
reviews, but of any kind we asked what this neural network would learn.
Well, now we know that,
of course it learns whatever it needs to learn to perform the sentence
completion properly and to do this,
it needs to learn English by itself. And that's exactly what it did.
It also learned about a lot of topics to be able to discuss them well,
what topics let's see,
we gave it a try and I was somewhat surprised when I saw that it was able to
continue a two minute paper script,
even though it seems to have turned into a history lesson.
What was even more surprising is that it could shoulder the two minute papers
tests. Or in other words,
I asked it to talk about the nature of fluid simulations and it was caught
cheating red-handed,
but then it continued in a way that was not only coherent bad,
had quite a bit of truth to it.
Note that there was no explicit instruction for the AI apart from it being
unleashed on the internet and reading it.
And now the next version appeared by the name GPT three.
This version is now more than a hundred times bigger.
So our first question is how much better can an AI get?
If we increase the size of a neural network, let's a look together.
These are the results on a challenging reading comprehension test as a function
of the number of parameters.
As you see around one and a half billion parameters,
which is roughly equivalent to GPT two, it has learned a great deal,
but it's understanding is nowhere near the level of human comprehension.
However, as we grow the network, something incredible happens.
Non-trivial capabilities start to appear as we approach the hundred billion
parameters. Look, it nearly matched the level of humans.
My goodness, this was possible before,
but only with neural networks that are specifically designed for a narrow task
in comparison,
GPT three is much more general let's test that generality and
have a look at five practical applications together.
One open AI made this AI accessible to a lucky few people,
and it turns out it has read a lot of things on the internet,
which contains a lot of code.
So it can generate website layouts from a written description
tool.
It also learned how to generate properly formatted plots from a tiny prompt
written in plain English, not just one kind many kinds,
perhaps the joy of technical PhD students around the world. Three,
it can properly type set mathematical equations from a plain English description
as well. Right?
It understands the kind of data we have in a spreadsheet in this case
population and feels the missing parts correctly.
And five,
it can also translate a complex legal text into plain language or
the other way around. In other words,
it can also generate legal text from our simple descriptions.
And as you see here, it can do much, much more.
I left the link to all of these materials in the video description. However,
of course this iteration of GPT also has its limitations. For instance,
we haven't seen the extent to which these examples are cherry-picked or in other
words,
for every good output that we Marvel at there might have been one or a dozen
tries that did not come out well. We don't exactly know,
but the main point is that working with GPD three is a really peculiar process
where we know that a vast body of knowledge lies within,
but it only emerges if we can bring it out with properly written prompts,
it almost feels like a new kind of programming that is open to everyone,
even people without any programming or technical knowledge.
If a computer is a bicycle for the mind, then GP T3 is a fighter jet.
Absolutely incredible. And to that,
the paper is vast would be an understatement.
We only scratched the surface of what it can do here.
So make sure to have a look. If you wish to know more about it,
the link is available in the video description.
I can only imagine what we will be able to do with GPT four and GPD
five in the near future. What a time to be alive.
What do you see here is an instrumentation for a previous paper that we covered
in this series, which was made by weights and biases.
I think organizing these experiments really showcases the usability of their
system weights and biases provides tools to track your experiments in your deep
learning project. Their system is designed to save you a ton of time and money,
and it is actively used in projects at prestigious labs,
such as open AI to at our research GitHub and more.
And the best part is that if you have an open source academic or personal
project, you can use their tools for free. It really is as good as it gets,
make sure to visit them through
wnb.com/papers or click the link in the video description to start tracking your
experiments in five minutes,
our thanks to weights and biases for the longstanding support and for helping us
make better videos for you. Thanks for watching and for your generous support.
And I'll see you next time.